[MUSIC PLAYING]
SCOTT VAN WOUDENBERG: My
name's Scott Van Woudenberg.
I'm a product manager
on Google Cloud.
And today we're going to talk
a little bit about architecting
for performance when
you're building large scale
applications in the cloud.
Just a quick process
note, I think
you've seen these slides
probably on some other talks,
but this session it has a Dory.
So you can pull up the app,
the Google Cloud Next app,
find this session, click
through to the Dory Q&A,
and submit questions
throughout the session
as you think of them,
rather than trying
to remember them until the end.
And at the end, the Q&A session,
we'll take questions both from
live questions
from the audience--
there's microphones that
you need to come up to--
and we'll alternate
between that and the Dory
if there are questions
on the Dory as well.
So just keep that in
mind, and let's get going.
So I'll just give you
a little bit more info
about what I'm going to cover.
I'm going to start with a
little bit of discussion
around the state of what
Moore's Law looks like today
and how the trend's been
going the last few years, what
the implications are for
scale up applications
or applications that depend
on scaling vertically.
We'll also talk about what kind
of challenges get introduced
and you have to start
dealing with when you start
re-architecting for more
scale out type applications
and tracking performance
in those types of systems.
And we'll do a
real world example,
or talk through some
examples from real world
application, which I'll talk
about it when we get to it.
And then, at the
end, we'll kind of
cover a little bit about
once we've kind of got
your performance
well understood,
what kinds of things you
can think about next,
and kind of optimize for,
and that sort of thing.
This graph kind of
shows the Moore's law.
The big question is this,
you've seen articles
on Moore's Law is dead, a bunch
of information around that.
Is that technically true?
Well, those who remember,
Moore's law is about transistor
count doubling every 18
months slash two years,
depending on who you talk to.
So you can see from this
graph, transistor count
continues to go up.
So that part of Moore's
law is not really dead,
but some of the important
characteristics that
also used to scale along
in roughly that frequency
are no longer holding.
And so, for example,
single thread performance
as measured by your
typical [? specing ?]
CPU type benchmark
continues to increase,
but not nearly at the
same rate as it used to.
The frequency of the CPUs
themselves, as well as
the power that they can actually
draw has sort of plateaued off.
There are some reasons for that.
It's called the power wall.
It's pretty easy--
it's basically
about getting that much power
to a small area of the chip,
the small die area,
without basically
melting the whole thing.
And then the number
of logical cores
continues to increase with
the transistor count, which
is good, but that kind of
signals even at the CPU
microarchitectural
layer they're already
kind of moving away from
the vertical scaling,
super high frequency,
higher and higher frequency,
to more of a scale out
configuration architecture
where they're just adding
more and more cores.
And so, taking advantage
of parallelism at the CPU
level to get more
performance out
of the same amount of power.
So how does this
impact large scale
application architectures?
Basically any of
scale up components
that you have become your
performance bottlenecks pretty
quickly, especially
if you're building
a service that serves--
it's a mobile app or something--
10,000 users, you
can probably do that
on one SQL database
running on one VM.
If you scale that up to
like 100 million users,
that's going to fall
down pretty quickly.
So large scale
application developers
or people that are
trying to evolve
their architectures to support
a larger, very fast growing user
base are having
to figure out how
to re-architect to their scale
up components and systems
to be more hard horizontally
scalable or scale out.
So examples include
like charting
your user base or your
users across multiple shards
of a database.
Maybe geo-specific-- so
all the users in Europe
are in one database,
all the users in the US
are in another database--
that's one example.
You can do the same
thing with front-ends.
You kind of build get
rid of the state that
sits in your front-ends
and do scale out.
You run multiple front-ends to
terminate your inbound client
connections and
things like that.
But all of this also
means that as you've
changed the
architecture, your system
becomes a lot more
complicated, it
gets a lot harder to
understand and reason
about what the overall
system performance looks like
and how to troubleshoot that.
There's a good analogy--
if you think about
like building high
availability of systems,
you've got to have redundancy.
You want to get rid of
single points of failures.
You can kind of use
a similar analogy
for when you're thinking about
performance of your application
or workload, in that if you've
got a scale up component
that becomes a single point
of a performance bottleneck.
It doesn't quite
roll off the tongue
like single point
of failure, but it
gets the point
across and kind of
gives you a good mental
model to keep in mind.
So going for a quick example,
if this it's just a basic web
browser, it's just
serving some content,
and you've got two variations.
On the left you've got one
where the database, and the web
server, and all the tools,
and everything are sitting
on one machine, it's
pretty easy for me
to measure total QPS or
total requests per second
that I can process here.
I can use my standard operating
system tools on Linux,
like Top and whatnot, to
see what system-- like,
is the database the thing
consuming all the CPU, is it
my web server, or whatever.
So that's pretty easy to
understand and figure out
where your bottlenecks are.
And even the
example on the right
where you've kind of
split that out, you've
now got two machines--
one that's dedicated just
for the database and one that's
then running your web server
tools.
You've only got two places
to look to kind of figure
out what is currently
limiting your performance.
So as my number of connections
grows, do I see a plateau.
I need to go look
at what system is
the thing that's causing that
and how to architect to fix it.
On the other hand, if I'm
building something quite a bit
more complicated-- like this is
an example of a real-time ads
bidding application--
if my bids per second
are hitting a cap,
and/or the latency
of each bit is
increasing as my number of bids
that I try to submit goes up,
how do I know where in
here the bottleneck is?
So maybe it's at the load
balancer, probably not.
It could be I'm not adding
enough Compute servers.
The bidding servers-- I might
not be scaling and adding
enough of them.
It could be many of the
different components here.
And so, understanding
which one it is it
becomes a lot more difficult.
And then, once you kind of--
not just performance
of your application,
but also, am I spending too
much money to deliver this?
In a system like this,
what's the most likely?
This is genomics
analysis, so you've
got a bunch of gene
sequencers that
are doing a gene
sequencing analysis,
dumping all that data into VMs
to ingest into this big HPC
cluster that also runs on VMs.
Of all these systems, which
one is probably the most likely
I'm overpaying for, or
that I can optimize or tune
to be more efficient,
or maybe try
a different type of
hardware component,
like optimize my computation
for GPUs for example.
And if I can get more
throughput that way,
that it might end up being
cheaper than continuing
to add more CPU VMs.
So that's just another example.
So earlier, I said we were going
to talk through some examples
from the real world, because
I think examples really
help cement these ideas.
And I'm going to use
examples from Compute Engine
itself, which is the
service that I work on.
And it's an infrastructure
as a service.
We rent VMs by the second.
And it's basically, A, a very
complicated, complex service,
it's got lot of different
components-- control
plane, data plane, actual VMs,
the underlying host machines,
the KVM host kernel
environment, and lots
of different components
to think about.
It's also got lots of customers
and is growing pretty rapidly,
so we're having to
re-architect different pieces
as the service
continues to grow,
and kind of identifying
which pieces those are
is kind of part of
this whole process.
And then, there's
obviously a huge variety
of use cases in infrastructure.
So people can use it for
whatever they currently have,
want to run, want to build.
So there is a lot of
different use cases,
a lot of different requirements,
different performance
characteristics that
different applications need,
and et cetera.
And this is kind of
the journey that we've
been on since we
launched the service
many years ago at this point.
And so, providing
examples from this I think
will help cement it.
So kind of step one for any
kind of performance analysis
that you want to do
on a complex system
is measure everything
you can think of.
We think in terms of what
are called service level
indicators.
And, essentially, a service
level indicator is simply
a metric that you want to
track, like number of VM exits,
for example, or plus the reason
for the VM exit, cache misses,
TLB misses, that sort of thing.
Those are all SLIs
that you can figure out
how to measure, and then
start analyzing over time,
and build dashboards around,
and start correlating
with potentially
performance issues
that your customers have.
Those are examples
at the VM level.
Higher up in the control
plane stack, like latency
of APIs requests.
Like, every time an API request
comes in for creating a VM,
how long does that take
before I can respond back?
And how long does it take
for the VM to spin up?
And that sort of thing.
So these are all examples of
the service level indicators
that are important.
And a good mental
model is, ask yourself,
what performance related things
do my customers care about?
Do they care about
spin up time of a VM?
Probably.
Do they care about the
number of TLB exits?
They probably don't know how
that affects their performance.
But if they have a
performance problem,
we could use that to
help troubleshoot it.
So that's another good example.
And just to kind of give you
some numbers, some examples,
you're probably not going
to start out quite this big.
And we didn't start out
this big either, but just
the jobs that run the virtual
machines themselves export
over 6,000 of these SLIs,
basically, every few seconds.
And so, we have a
massive number of these
that we analyze and collect.
And 2,200 of that 6,000 just
come from the virtual machine
monitor itself, the process
that is sitting there
kind of monitoring the VM and
what it's doing, and helping
do the I/O operations
and things like that.
So you know you
won't start that big,
but it's pretty easy to
get that big if you're
building a complicated system.
So here's an example I referred
to a little bit earlier,
like creating an instance.
This is probably one of the
most important operations
that a service that
sells VMs is doing.
So customers tend to
care a lot about it.
And when we measure
this, this graph
is actually from an
internal dashboard
that we have that measures
this kind of constantly.
So the vertical
axis is how long it
takes to create
the VM, basically
from the time the Compute
Engine receives the API
requests to when the guest OS
finishes booting, because we
have a signal for that.
It hits the metadata
server, and that's
how we tell when it
finishes booting.
And then the horizontal axis
is just kind of over time.
So we've been measuring
this for many years.
So I just took a snapshot
of this dashboard
for a few months.
I think it's over like a six
month period a while back.
So once I've got a lot of
metrics that I'm gathering,
what do I do with them?
So the next step is to
set targets for what
those metrics should be.
And again, we started with
service level indicators,
that's the raw
metrics themselves.
Now, we talk about
service level objectives.
And a service level objective
is basically like, all right,
well, here's what I'm measuring
for, let's say, VM create time,
and it's on the order
of 35, 40 seconds.
That sounds good.
Is that good enough?
Do I want to set my SLO
at where I am today?
Am I getting customers
that are already
complaining that my VM
take too long to spin up?
Maybe that is a good
signal that tells me, well,
where I am today is not
maybe where I need to be.
So setting the SLO
more aggressively
and then figuring out what
I need to do to hit that
is definitely a good
way to go about it.
Many of you, if you've
read the SRE handbook,
you'll probably recognize some
of these terms that I'm using--
SLOs, SLIs.
These are all metrics that our
SRE teams use for availability
of a service as well.
And they map very well to
performance availability,
if you can think of it that way.
Is my performance consistent?
And what consistent
level am I delivering it?
What happens when
I fall out of that?
Et cetera.
So you set the objective, your
customers can help tell you
when or how to set
that objective,
or what to set it to.
And if there's no
obvious target and you
haven't gotten any complaints
about a particular performance
characteristic, it's
probably fine to set the SLO
where it is today, and then
when you start getting feedback
from customers that it
might not be good enough,
then reconsider where
you would set it.
Another key thing
about SLOs is you
have to have kind of similar--
there's a lot of details in
the SRE handbook about this
as well, but you have
to have a plan of action
for either, if I set my
SLO at a better target
than where I can deliver
today, you need to have a plan
to get it to that new target.
You also need a
reaction plan if you
set it to roughly where you're
delivering performance today,
the reaction plan is, well, what
happens if all of a sudden I
stopped meeting that SLO?
Let's say I did a
push of a new binary
or a new component of my system,
and all of a sudden my VM
create time went below SLO.
I have a certain
amount of time to react
to that, that's my SLO budget.
And the reaction plan really
needs to be very quantified.
For something like VM create, if
we go from creating VMs in 30,
40 seconds to
taking five minutes,
that could break many
customers' applications.
And so it's critical that the
plan be immediately actionable.
If it was a roll out,
then roll it back.
Get back to the state
where we're meeting SLO,
then go figure out what
went wrong, go fix the bug
that in that push,
whatever the case may be.
So that's essentially,
the purpose of the SLOs,
and the importance of
having that scripted action
plan ahead of time.
Because if you don't have
that, and the first time you go
[? out ?] [? of ?] SLO, you're
scrambling to try to figure out
what you should do.
There should be a really
established playbook for that.
So just to kind of give
you a visual example
of creating the SLO, we go back
to the create-instance example.
And essentially,
setting the SLO is
like drawing a line
at where I think
is acceptable for
create performance.
And obviously, since the
vertical axis is time,
lower is better for VM create.
That means VMs are
getting created faster.
So the other lines are actually
some of our internal systems
that we measured, like different
components and different flows
of our internal provisioning
and resource allocation systems.
And so that's why this graph has
a lot of different bars on it.
But that top bar is the one
that measures when the guest
OS is finished booting.
So the next step of
this whole process
is basically go back to step 1.
You are going to do this over
and over and over, especially
as you're iterating
on your application,
your user base is
growing, you're
finding these new
architectural limitations
or scale up components that
are currently your bottleneck,
you're reevaluating
where you have set SLOs,
because a customer
you know reported
that they had an issue
at such and such a time.
You go back and look at what
your telemetry says, and of,
but we were within SLO.
Maybe that means we
need to change the SLO
and start figuring
out how to do better.
So if you get enough
customers that
are complaining about
a specific thing
not working well
enough or fast enough,
that's usually a
really good sign
that you have to readjust
and rethink that SLO.
And basically, you
have customers.
As your customer
base grows, you're
going to be doing
investigations with them,
they're going to
have issues, you're
going to go look
at your telemetry,
you're not going
to find anything
that is measuring
exactly what it
is that's causing
them the problem,
and so you're going to
work with them on a repro,
you're going to have them
repro it, whatever the case,
you'll eventually start
adding additional SLIs,
defining new SLOs, et cetera.
So this is a very
iterative process,
and will continue as
new investigations go
on, new troubleshoot with
customers, you'll add new SLIs
and set new SLOs, at some point
that kind of process stops,
and you are no longer
finding new things to add,
but you're still encountering
customers having issues,
and basically your internal
telemetry has taken you
as far as it can when it comes
to measuring what the customer
performances is.
And, at that point
you have to become
a customer of your own service.
So essentially,
you want to build
you're SLIs in a way
that it directly reflects
what the customer sees.
And a good example of that is,
my original metric was, time
to when the guest
OS finished booting.
That's not the whole story.
Most customer applications,
most users, if I'm SSH,
like you they don't care when
the guest OS finishes booting,
they care when they can
actually get access to it
or it can start serving.
So it probably needs network
to be provisioned as well.
So basically a better
customer facing metric
is from the time
we received the API
call to when you can SSH to it.
And those new lines
that you see--
that orange line in the middle,
that was the original guest OS
boot line, and I've just added
like the network provisioning
steps and network
path programming--
internal and external network
programming, and all that--
to this graph.
And comically enough-- it
wasn't funny at the time--
but this was when we learned
that our network provisioning
time scaled roughly with how
big our service was getting,
and figured out that
we have to go fix that
and re-architect network
programming model
to make sure that
doesn't happen.
So again, you get really
interesting signals
when you start measuring
from the external customers
perspective, rather than just
relying on your internal SLIs.
So what we end up
having to do, is we
built a service that
measures performance
just like the customer.
So it runs benchmarks.
It can run workloads.
It's called perfkit benchmarker.
It's open source.
It's on GitHub.
You just search GitHub
for perfkit benchmarker,
you'll find it.
There's also perfkit
explorer, which is basically
a dashboarding and analytics
framework that makes it easier
to build graphs,
kind of like the ones
that you saw in
some of my examples.
And you start using PKB
or a PKB-like service--
so it depends on
whatever your services,
but you basically end
up building something
that measures the performance
like your customers do.
So if it's a mobile
application, you
are probably gathering
telemetry out at the client end.
You're running tests that mimic
client behavior connecting
to your servers.
Maybe you do it on
actual mobile devices,
maybe you do it on
emulators, whatever the case.
But having an
automated framework
that lets you launch these
tests and rerun them constantly
in all of your
environments, including
your pre-production
environments,
like your developer
environments, your staging
environments, those become
critical to catching issues,
regressions, SLO
violations, et cetera
as you develop and build
new versions of your product
or application.
So the key with measuring
your own service,
it's a prober-based system.
So you're probing from the
perspective of the customer.
So in the VM, like in
the example before,
we were probing by basically
running a service that measures
when I can SSH to the VM.
So that means I run
something inside the VM
that lets me know
when that succeeds.
And a lot of the prober-based
benchmarks are the same way.
You spin up a VM, you
install whatever benchmark
you want to run,
you run it, and then
you collect the results
back, and graph the results
and see how things are going.
So now we'll do a quick demo.
Can you flip over to the demo?
So the demo I'm going to
run is TCP round robin,
which is basically
part of the PKB suite,
but it's a netperf
benchmark that
measures the VM to VM latency--
round trip latency between
two virtual machines.
So I'm just going to
kick off the demo first,
and then I'll talk a little
bit about what it's doing.
It takes a few
minutes, so I'm going
to have to dance around
while it's actually running.
So let's quickly take a look
at the actual script itself.
All the script is
doing is basically
calling PKB, which is the main
kind of orchestration script,
and gives it a
bunch of arguments.
One of the arguments
is netperfconfig.yaml,
so I'll pull that
up in a minute.
But basically, once
PKB finishes its runs,
it collects all the data
in a local directory,
runs a plotting tool
that creates a nice CDF,
and then uploads the CDF to
a storage bucket, which I'll
pull up as soon as it finishes.
So the CDF is basically
just a distribution
a graph that shows the
distribution of what
the performance looks like.
So as a cumulative
distribution function,
it's a really nice
way to look at what
my average performance is,
what long-tail performance is.
It kind of shows you that graph,
and I'll show you in a minute,
it'll make more sense.
A couple of notes about
the benchmarks themselves
and kind of the
guidelines around this--
actually, let me quickly
pull up the config file.
So it's pretty
straightforward as well.
All it's saying is I'm
using N1 standard 2 VMs.
I'm using the internal
network to do my measurement.
I'm not going out
through external IPs.
The benchmark I want to run.
How many histogram buckets
I want to collect for it.
And I actually ran the
multi-zone argument,
which means it's spinning
up 10 pairs of VMs
in three different zones
across three different regions
and running the RR benchmark for
60 seconds on each pair of VMs
to measure to get a good
sample size of the round trip
time between VMs in those zones.
So let's see how it's doing.
Cool.
Yeah, it's still running.
You can see it's SSHing in
to the VMs running the tool.
And it will be
pulling the data back.
So kind of talking
a little bit more
generally about benchmarking--
how to pick the how to pick
your benchmarks that you
want to use.
Microbenchmarks are
usually a good start.
A microbenchmark like
SPECint, SPEC CPU, Coremark.
TCP-RR is actually also
considered a microbenchmark,
but it's a little bit
more representative
of what an actual real
application might want to do,
or a performance
characteristic that
might be valuable to understand
for a real application.
Microbenchmarks in
and of themselves
are not always a good indicator
of what your workload is
going to experience.
Real workloads tend to be a
lot more complicated than that.
And so, you can start
with microbenchmarks,
but you should
probably have a plan
for doing something
that's more like running
things that are more like what
your customers are running.
For GCE, that includes running
benchmarks and microbenchmarks
in combination.
So maybe I'll fire up you
know SPECint or Coremark,
or whatever.
And at the same time, I'm
also spinning up a netperf
to do some network traffic.
TCPstream maybe to
push a bunch of network
either out to the internet
or some internet endpoint
or between VMs.
I might also spin up
like an IOstat or FIO
benchmark at the
same time, which
is hammering on my storage,
whether it's local SSD, or PD,
or what have you.
So now I've got the VM actually
doing a combination of things,
and I can start really
getting a sense for,
oh, well, when I start
doing a lot of disk IO,
my CPU benchmark slows
down for some reason.
You should probably
go understand
why that is, because chances
are customers are probably
going to be doing things more
complicated than just running
one CPU-heavy benchmark,
or CPU-heavy workload.
And then, better yet
then combinations
of microbenchmarks, is actually
workload-based benchmarks.
So you can get a sense-- for
GCE, we know lots of customers
run NoSQL databases
and Apache LAMP
stacks for web serving
and stuff like that.
So there are open-source
benchmarks out there
that will measure the
throughput of a Cassandra
cluster or a MongoDB cluster.
Aerospike's got a
great set of test tools
for their in-memory
NoSQL database.
So find the benchmarks
or find the workloads
that your customers
are running, even
if it's just a piece of it,
and start measuring those.
And then, kind of
the better still
is when you actually can run
exactly what your customers are
running in exactly
the same config.
And that's not always possible.
For us, we sometimes
can, we sometimes can't.
We can get a sense for
what they might be doing,
we'll have a meeting with them,
talk about what they're doing,
and then try to
replicate that experience
in our own environment
using similar configs.
Sometimes we actually can work
with them and get the benchmark
or get the workload that
they're actually running,
get a copy of it.
And they just give us
a bunch of dummy data,
and we can do the
same exact thing
that they're doing,
just with data
that is kind of placeholder.
All right, cool.
So it finished.
It took about a few minutes.
So I managed to cover the time.
So I'm just going to go to the
GCS bucket now, refresh it,
and you can see the timestamp
on it is just a few seconds ago.
And so, it did--
it actually worked.
Woohoo, demo gods
smiled upon me.
So this is what I was
talking about of CDF.
So this shows you what the
distribution of your VM
to VM latency is in
three different zones
that we have that are across
three different regions.
And so, kind of the
50th percentile.
This is like your average,
median, round trip
time between VMs.
And then you can see,
up toward the top,
some zones are slightly better
in the long tail than others.
But the more vertical
this is, the better.
So this is pretty good
indicator that things
are working reasonably
well here in these zones.
OK, we can flip back to the--
cool.
Let's see-- OK, so now
I've got my SLOs defined.
I'm meeting them all.
I can catch regressions in
new versions of my system
before they hit production.
What now?
What's kind of the
next step from here?
A lot of that then
becomes turning your focus
toward making your
systems more efficient.
You've probably got a backlog
of some re-architecting
you need to do, depending
on how fast your customer
base is growing, or how
your user base is growing.
So am I spending way too much
money on solving this problem?
Is there something I could
be doing more efficient?
Is there some product
that I can use
that gives me a better TCO--
Total Cost Per whatever
it is I'm trying to do?
And kind of to that
point, it really helps
to start thinking about, what
is your cost for performance?
So what is it costing
me to hit, for example,
the 30-second
create time for VMs?
How much more would
it cost me engineering
investment-wise, resource-wise?
Maybe I can shard my
control plane even further
to let it scale up further.
What's that going to cost me
to get another 10 seconds off
of my VM create time?
So thinking about the
performance, and cost
of the performance
you're trying to get,
and how much it
would take to get
kind of next level performance
really helps with this process.
Another example is, if I'm
doing ML image training--
I'm training and
machine learning model
to do image recognition.
During the training, what's
my pennies per image, right?
Hopefully, it's not
even pennies per image.
If it is, you're
probably doing it wrong.
And then, once you've
got it trained,
what's my classification cost?
How many pennies per
classification am I spending?
And can I do better than that?
So find the products
that fit your patterns.
What you want to do--
these are some
examples for GCE, but I
think this is fairly
generally applicable.
You want to find discounts
where you can get it.
So for our committed
use discounts are really
good for any time
you've got like kind
of a steady amount of workload,
steady some number of VMs,
if you buy committed use
discount that kind of covers
the number of
resources that you're
using for where
the green line is,
you're getting a really, really
good discount, up to like 57%,
I think, discount if
you buy a three-year CUD
for the cost of that steady
state use amount of resources.
So it works really well.
If you have diurnal
workloads, that
changes the equation
a little bit.
But for the steady
state stuff, CUDs
is a really great way to
save a bunch of money.
Sorry, too quick.
Wrong button.
Preemptable VMs-- if you've just
got batch-style computation,
that you need to launch a bunch
of VMs, do some computation,
and then just delete
them all, preemptable VMs
is a great model for that.
They're 80% cheaper
than normal VMS,
and as long as you've
got a worker based system
that can handle a worker
going away, remembers
what work it gave to the one
that just died, and gives it
to another one, this is a really
good way to save a lot of money
as well.
Custom machine types--
it's another feature
that we have for GCE
that basically makes it
so that you can create your
VM to fit your workload,
not try to figure out how to
get your workload to scale up
to use the rest of the resources
that you have on a fixed shape
VM.
Other examples--
the ala cart nature
of being able to add
things like local SSD,
different GPUs, you can add that
to any machine type or any VM,
as opposed to only being able
to pick for a subset of VM.
So that's also another
way to help save money.
If it turns out that being
able to run your workload,
and maybe you find
a library that's
optimized to do a specific
computation against the GPU,
and it's significantly
cheaper than doing it on CPU--
like, being able to
add a GPU to the VM
is pretty helpful without
having to spend a bunch of money
also on local SSD,
perhaps, or whatever
else might be attached.
So just to kind of recap,
start by just measuring
everything you can think of.
Think about what's important to
your customers, focus on that.
Define the SLOs
based on either where
your customers are complaining.
Or if they're not complaining,
probably setting them
to where it is today is fine.
You're going to go through
that process a lot.
You're going to get
customers complaining.
You're going to investigate.
You're going to find new
things you need to measure,
new SLOs you need to
set, existing SLOs
need to set higher
or lower depending
on what you're measuring.
And then, eventually,
you'll have
to start measuring
as your customers do,
or from your
customers perspective,
and building a service--
or it might not be a
service, but that's
the easy conceptual
way to think about it,
build a service for measuring
the performance of your system
as if it's from what the
customer's experience.
So I just wanted
to give a shout out
to some folks that helped
me with this, Al Hamel.
He runs the performance
engineering team.
They built PKB.
They built the infrastructure
to run all that stuff internally
for GCE.
He's very intimately involved
with a lot of our customers,
working on analyzing
their performance
and stuff like that.
Eric Hankland--
actually, thank him
for my demo succeeding, because
of firewalls and whatnot.
And then Bryan was one
of our marketing people
that helped me rehearse,
basically-- counting my umms.
[MUSIC PLAYING]